and so what I want to do here is talk
about the multiverse in relation to
all-new all-different marvel and the
reason why is because those of you who
are getting in a Marvel Comics for the
first time what you're seeing here is
Marvel effectively building their
multiverse but what they're also doing
is drawing on elements of the multiverse
as it existed prior to Secret Wars and
so I think that in order to really
understand everything that's going on we
need to have an understanding of the
structure of the multiverse as it
existed prior to seeker wars in order to
understand how its unfolding and all-new
all-different marvel
so when Marvel Comics prior to Secret
Wars the multiverse was structured in a
fashion that saw various dimensions and
realms existing alongside and his
branches of their respective universes
which in turn composed the multiverse
itself using the main Marvel Universe as
an example this universe was referred to
as earth-616 and was where a bulk of the
stories took place branching off from
earth-616 were a series of dimensions
and the concept of the Asgardians is
really a good place for us to start here
and Marvel Comics Asgard is quite
literally a giant chunk of land situated
in a dimension by itself the other
worlds of Muspelheim Alfheim vanaheim
Jotunheim swaddle hime hell and enough
hime all exists within their own
dimensions as well now the key here is
that Marvel never really explored these
territories and all we knew was that
there was a planet in each of these
dimensions dedicated to the inhabitants
of these various realms but the other
half of this equation was that there
were times when these dimensions were
depicted as pocket universes which is to
say smaller universes inside of larger
universes on the whole though it's just
up to personal preference regarding what
it is that you prefer but for the sake
of our discussion the concept of
dimensions operating separate from one
another will serve find now to take
these concepts of dimensions a little
further Dormammu one of the most
powerful entities in Marvel Comics and
dr. Strange's most dangerous foe exists
in a place called the Dark Dimension
and the Microverse existed as a
dimension that could be accessed by
shrinking down to the smallest high as
possible using Pym particles however
while these locations vary from earth
light to wildly exotic all of these
dimensions exist under the umbrella of
the earth-616 universe conversely the
ultimate universe referred to as earth
16:10 had its own version of Asgard the
corresponding Asgardian worlds the dark
dimension of Dormammu and presumably the
Microverse although this was never
really explored in addition to this each
universe had its own cosmic entities
like eternity but also had his own
versions of Galactus the various
Celestials and so on the having said
that the multiverse as it existed prior
to seeker Wars was the collection of all
these various universes
the respective dimensions functioning as
a cohesive unit which was overseen by
the Living Tribunal and between these
various universes existed what are
referred to as the many angled ones
which were beings like Shu McGrath
because the history of the many angled
ones was never really explored in Marvel
Comics this race was only ever really
seen on a couple of occasions and rarely
ever entered into an actual universe
itself the only time this happened was
during Marvel premiere issue number 14
when she McGrath killed the ancient one
allowing dr. strange to become the
sorcerer supreme as well as several
other subsequent appearances and the
Thanos imperative when death was killed
in an alternate reality which kept
everyone and everything from dying in
that alternate universe now outside of
the multiverse in a dimension that was
unexplored or the beyonders now how they
got there and how long they had been in
existence was never really explored and
in truth their appearance and Hickman's
story of time runs out was the most
information we had ever received on any
of them and so after all of this has
been said the question is how does this
translate into all-new all-different
marvel
because all-new all-different marvel
starts eight months after Secret Wars
which hasn't ended yet it's really
difficult for us to know exactly how the
multiverse came into existence but using
some of the past information we can
basically piecemeal things together
starting with the one above all because
this being exists as the all-powerful
creator of the Marvel multiverse and
truth until such a time as Marvel stage
that the one above all is either living
or dead we can't really assume whether
he's alive or not and so others gonna
kind of leave this out there for people
to decide and just kind of run with The
Living Tribunal is up in the air as well
since it was created by the one above
all to maintain balance in the
multiverse but was shown to have been
killed by the beyonders during time runs
out and so again we don't know if the
Living Tribunal is back the cosmic
entities however are not necessarily as
ambiguous the being who was depicted in
the eighth force preview from Avengers
issue number zero was actually a being
called singularity who is a new
character that's basically a pocket
dimension that gained awareness and
manifested itself in the main Marvel
universe however beings like eternity
and infinity are the representation of
the universe itself
and so if Marvel sticks with past
information like they're doing now it
would make sense that eternity exists in
some fashion since eternity would
effectively represent this new universe
finally in The Ultimates preview which
was also from Avengers issue number zero
when America Chavez traveled to a rip in
space to close it off Marvel established
that the mini ankled ones still exist in
the space between universes which tells
us that the multiverse also exists
although its size is unknown furthermore
during an interview with Comics Alliance
al Ewing had explicitly stated that
Galactus was going to be an enemy of the
Ultimates and of course we know Galactus
to be one of the cosmic entities but
more so than that how Ewing had stated
that he intended to have a storyline
that would involve the dreaming
celestial which is one of the many
Celestials that existed prior to secret
wars and so what's basically happening
here is Marvel is preparing to expand
their universe and eventually introduce
more Universal constructs as time goes
on but again because this is all-new
all-different marvel it's hard to know
exactly word is that they're going but
armed with the information in this video
I think you should be pretty well
prepared for whatever it is that happens
to pop up and however it is that their
multiverse expands and you'll be able to
kind of compare and contrast the
previous multiverse with the multiverse
as it grows in all-new all-different
marvel
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end and I hope it was
helpful to you guys and I will catch you
all later peace